les jambes dégueulasse
vous êtes plusieurs abandons
[Rires]
l'été elle peut gagner 20 cm vous vous
rendez compte 20 cm tandis que la dame
de fer l'hiver se rétrécit de 4 à 8 cm
et ses pattes ou alors ça j'adore elle
peut aussi pencher d'un côté ou de
l'autre en fonction de la rocade le
soleil
oui mais le record nous avec goût avec
le rappel des troupes
c'est vraiment vrai la rumeur à skis
parlerons flotte sur la mer morte et
c'est un truc que jamais connu meilleure
et plus je me noie mois dans l'eau
balajo flotte
mission accomplie pour tahri km qui ont
réalisé les deux clichés comme eux des
frères belges terminent leur photo c'est
parfait c'est bon c'est fait le cas
ça me pique le zizi oui est ce que votre
tour eiffel peu penché de 18 cm que le
soleil est capable de tout parce que
l'athlète la presse était un été de
canicule en 1976 j'irai jusqu'au bout 18
cm
clp qui vient bombe alors monsieur
michel berson soleil qui s'appelle et
beaucoup de visites et original en tout
cas on en est où moi je suis perdu bon
oui mottaki de travail acquis à la
russie est carrément ces tirs et les
personnes âgées moi ici sur ce plateau
j'ai toujours dit ne me fait pas
confiance jamais non mathieu s'il a
toujours dit je crois fabrice vie non
surtout pas on ne me croit pas bon on
est d'accord je veux dire non mais je te
demande pas de me croire le problème
c'est que quand je t'amène des données
objectives comme l'adresse tout à coup
ça t'intéresse maintenant je te crois
pas qu'il n'y avait pas d'avoir la weiss
les normes et tu ne crois pas mais tu
peux vérifier mathieu à ses succès il ya
un truc qui s'appelle le cerveau tu peux
l'utiliser de temps en temps tu as le
droit
fondamental je te parle en fait
j'étais normal
j'ai des bretonnants
l'avantagé quand j'ai reçu congé gendre
à l'écouté
[Musique]
face à la mer face à la mer ça me tape à
l'oeil je la connais direct jake ça sera
la mère mon grâce à la merci ça face à
la mer et la faute rouve et le go
comment s'appelle le compositeur le
compositeur arias autre chose jean reno
dans télésiège suspendu à une
montgolfière fred fulgence et lens à
6500 mètres d'altitude avec ce souhait
pousse tout flanc le jumper
professionnels réalise un nouvel exploit
un ballet acrobatique aérien risque est
préparé répété quasi millimétré pour
éviter au maximum l'improvisation avant
d'ouvrir son parachute et de s'offrir
une session intense de speed riding
entre les deux savoie son parachute
hésite mais c'est vers là plus à que
wolf raid fut gêne pour cette vidéo
publicitaire
pendant quelques secondes ils caressent
les sommets pas vraiment décidé à
prendre une piste noire
il a fallu cinq mois de travail 15
essais en quatre jours pour donner cette
impression de facilité
merci en tout cas écoutez ci-haut - je
n'osais pas les faits un mauvais esprits
mauvais ça le débat je vous dis bonne
continuation à nous venger des jv le mal
était vive la république et vive la
france